the intimacy is what's scary and that's
where the treasure is until you until
what do you think happens in there like
do you because that's that's the fear
the fear is if you really know me you
will run in the other direction because
I am fundamentally broken and unlovable
mhm and so I front a certain way to be a
certain person who can create the
appearance of lovability when you drop
all of that and you're like well this is
who I am that's terrifying because you
know there is something deep down that
feels like if you really knew me you
would find me repulsive this is the
definition of intimacy it only brings
more intimacy and connection that's all
there is in there and that's what
presence brings